this week we've got lost and found
white upcharge and anti influence what
notes were those remember Oh pianos
I miss Ethiopian food it does sound like
an EPO yo pian restaurant soundtrack ah
yeah so for our first story this wife
from India she had been looking for her
husband and heard the father of her two
children since 2016 she's a real [ __ ]
he's getting away
what if he got lost the second part
helped the first part if he got lost
what if it was a really sad story no
[ __ ] no wives and wives are horrible
I apologize I'm not smiling I didn't
even catch that until he said fun wife
species is very bitch-like
you have to get to the root of why
though the husband's fall because
they're so can you go back to your the
theme I just gotta say this did keep the
bar tell you that he hit a car no he did
not
yeah can you please explain how you hit
this car and then you leave me colleges
when did this my articles in 20 minutes
I think everyone wants to know no I want
to know IV no IV no no open another tab
open off-the-record we'll talk about it
okay good finish this I'm not gonna
forget so yeah he ended up leaving his
wife and kids and he was found because a
family member of the wife was looking on
tik-tok and saw that he was full was on
tik-tok that was dancing yeah I just
picture like googoo I picture that one
Indian guy that does all the hip-hop
[ __ ] with the noise change he just sold
oh the one that we use you had the
funnel
another knowledge he looks like him
though but yeah no clue well yeah that
guy he was finally I mean this guy was
finally found what a loser
they just picked you're middle-aged
indeed man I'll take time do it [ __ ]
lip-synching get dancing so it turns out
that this dude he has gone into a
relationship with the trans woman and
that's who was in that video with him
and so when they approached him like
like the cops and stuff cuz the family
and the wife and the family went to the
cops to try to be like hey what the hell
we found my husband and when they talked
to him he said that he left because of
my wife's a [ __ ] yeah pretty much
because their home home disputes that
could not be resolved yeah but at the
end of this story he ended up going back
to her so that was all like weird
she's scary I gotta go home I can't play
anymore I gotta go home
I'm scared well what have you thought of
having problems with with this new
girlfriend
uh-huh maybe at first he was like I get
the best of both worlds we could be like
best buds but then at the same time you
you know you're like a lady too so like
you're describing your own feelings on
this matter no no Luc is kids now having
their father back and at the end of that
story
that's just like weird like why don't
you just fit like officialize the
divorce because you're just like leaving
your kids hanging and then they just
have this like I know right daddy left
us right I mean I think the most
important part of this story though is
this tik-tok account yes yeah
what kind of content this dude was to
because I couldn't find what they never
show that [ __ ] this is the dad he was
very similar to what I was picturing
and then the mom with the two kids so
that's him in the girlfriend yeah it was
makes me so sad when kids are yeah yeah
it's like come on they're young enough
to not remember but his tik-tok account
though was he doing like scooter tricks
was he doing dancing cuz like they don't
describe it I know but my imagination is
just going wild right now do you have
really shitty kids though I will say cuz
I always think about this you know you
know about patricide right yeah a
certain percentage of population
kids wise kills their parents every year
so that's I having a shitty kid like
what was those Menendez brothers yes
they were getting abused no no right so
a lot of people say like well the
parents did that or influenced them in
some way I'm sure that that's a part of
it but [ __ ] dude sometimes you just have
a shitty kid and like they want to kill
you or whatever yeah so maybe he was
running away from a bad situation I saw
a movie where a kid even in as a man
your book a hairdryer into a his mom
taking a bath and electrocuted her [ __ ]
like that happens a lot man
that's a movie though oh oh but that
[ __ ] can be real yeah it's probably
based off some truth yeah Oh traumatize
I saw that [ __ ] when I was like 6 at my
friend's house let's just get dogs and
cats and safe loved Oh sir put some dogs
kill their owners yep we live in a dark
world on her side I don't believe it
dance why is everything so negative here
do not remove some cats gonna be some
cats sleep on babies in the baby
suffocate in the night so we're saying
that sometimes it's okay to run away
from your family sometimes it's okay to
run away from your family cuz they're
annoying that's that's what I say you're
losing the guy was justified he could
have been I don't know I don't know him
individually yeah I think that's really
true why are we so judgy why see it's
just that side I thought all Indian moms
were [ __ ] when I was a kid what why but
now you know that they're not right
those are like so my best friend that
grew up on my street they all show their
bellies you know like when they wear
like a traditional dress yeah the moms
like this the grandmas like this the
daughters like this they're all like
this and I'm like there's no sexy ass
Indian family and so I was just like
they like really want to get it on all
the time
part sees a pregnant lady with her shirt
coming out of her Bellamy's like what a
[ __ ] [ __ ] like a lot of them the
traditional where it's like this
where are you going they're part of the
boring world you guys didn't have an
Indian best friend eating on time Bobby
how old are you probably like nine or
ten
oh my damn there's no free no family no
should have known better
he's a little kid okay excuse me he's a
little kid go over there thank you Steve
listen he's cultured when you're a kid
we're on the same side all sorts of
weird [ __ ] I used to think that people
who spoke another language just couldn't
speak clearly and I was like what's
wrong with them why can't they just talk
regularly because their tongue all
twisted up for some [ __ ] ya know because
I'm stupid kid I thought people that
stuttered not started what's the what's
the word I thought they all did it on
purpose I I thought that kids they did I
had that thing thought because my little
cousin she would do it on purpose
Oh fun for attention yeah she's
desperate for attention no poor girl I
thought the kids in wheelchairs were
lucky because I got to sit down all day
I thought that I was like that's so cool
my aunt told me that when she first
encountered white people she literally
thought they were going make she would
try to copy them that's my mindset when
I was a kid I remember thinking exactly
that [ __ ] no I want to stay on the
offensive side story it's not offensive
this children thinking Music Festival in
Detroit that gonna be held in August
called afro future fest afro future yeah
and so they are in the news because
initially they had an early bird people
of color ticket priced at $10 and an
early bird non people are known for $20
so they were saying they were charging
white people with double the price
that's not cool but if you're white you
can just show up in blackface and get
cheaper that's where max see big losses
what about that what about that white
lady he'll look like
a part of the end of yak rights but
she's going what were they thinking
that's so rude so I know right so they
were swinging so there was what's rude
about it is about to ask that it's
racist it's discrimination like why why
are you trying to say white it's
actually illegal that's illegal
yeah it's illegal also we yeah like I
might have to I might have to pay the
[ __ ] I mean think about the white are
you half if white people are white this
company but how come it's like adults
can't go to check your cheese right yes
they can oh you met single males
yeah don't single male dogs
establishments they already have this
we're like we only want the young people
the okay so they said that it's that
quote affording joy and pleasure is
unfortunately still a privilege in our
society for people of color and we
believe everyone should have access to
receiving such so that's the reason why
they wanted to separate I can't stand by
that because okay I believe in locals
discounts right in tourist areas well in
it because that they don't discriminate
by culture it's like they know that
there's they're dealing with inflated
prices in their town because tourism so
like in Hawaii or like other places dude
oh man yeah they'll give you the locals
discount right show your driver's
license yeah I think that's fine and I
don't think that's like ever you can't
encourage it you under the protected
I forgot the term but like you know your
race your age your gender or yeah
whatever
yeah it's discrimination yeah yeah like
these are like protected groups and so
they're saying that this was illegal so
Eventbrite which is the site that was
doing the ticket sales they were doing a
ticket sells they tweeted this and it
says charging different prices based on
race or ethnicity clearly violates our
Terms of Service we are giving the
creators of this event a chance to do
the right thing and change their pricing
but will have to remove the
they don't comply hashtag Afro future
fest so what ended up happening is that
they doubled the prices even more the
event organizers tweeted this out oh no
and it says for the safety of our
community family elders who receive
threats from white supremacist and youth
who were subjected to seeing racist
comments on our I do page afro Future
Fest has changed our ticket model to $20
general omission and suggested donation
for non polar on Eventbrite but then
after that you bet fright was like you
still can't do that what the [ __ ] are
they see a donation thing so fans of
removing that it's like this is like the
perfect example of like people who have
kind of good intention like good
intentions but they like execute way
like in the wrong direction yeah well
they think it's what intentions but else
criminais ssin yeah that's what's
amazing about it yeah and they're just
assuming that if you're not of color
then you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] it's like
that's [ __ ] up like it's just like it
stems from like okay like there's like
the whole like white privilege
thingamabob and then they just like slip
it like you but that implies that
there's something wrong with me because
I'm white and I'm like I'm just over it
just like I don't I don't yeah I don't
know what I did yeah it's [ __ ] up like
I'm just a guy man why you can't
discriminate against Esther's maybe
sucked I don't think that I'm actually
related to slave owners I know it's not
some people are and and should they have
to pay more for gas or whatever the [ __ ]
yeah that's [ __ ] it gets weird it's
just a weird thing yeah should all
people pay the same price as us they
don't they don't maybe get a discount
that's why should they step it up and
because they're the ones I [ __ ] up
more than we did no because we're
playing that's a good argument it's like
thanks we inherit the old people's
problems so they should be paying more
to fix this [ __ ] forget it cuz I mean
that's what's really happy to be that
bride should send them a thing hey bingo
nights are all gonna be the same now
Martin Luther King wasn't about this
[ __ ] man like he wasn't like we got a
separate I'll everybody and make sure
that when white people around I feel
really uncomfortable and all this [ __ ]
he was like oh we should all be around
each other that's what it's all about
yeah and
like I read some story recently of like
a college let an graduating class all
graduate together as black people like
so they could be separate from the rest
of the of the integrated group because
they didn't want to be around white
people all the graduating or whatever
yeah that's weird I'm sure like that is
just leave it even in colleges even if
it's like the ethnics a centered
fraternity or sorority they still can't
exclude people so if you're Asian you
want to apply for like a Latino sorority
basically they still have to take you so
that's what I thought was weird it's
like you want to be like that's what
that's what I think a lot of things are
happening in media right now that that
influence people into thinking like if
I'm around a white person that's
uncomfortable for me because they [ __ ]
me over I mean I think it's because of
what we keep seeing which we will talk
about later but like you know why people
calling the cops on people of color for
no reason but their individual actions I
agree it is happening like the whole
group mind it's like oh [ __ ] one of us
is being attacked
right it makes everyone recede into into
their tribe right like like what
happened to Trayvon Martin right this
guy named George Zimmerman who's a
Mexican dude he's like he's like but but
the media made sure to try to paint him
out as white yeah as white as black as
possible right it was weird it was like
you take a Mexican guy and I'm not I'm
not even saying like you know I'm not
saying all Mexicans obviously but that's
what that's where we're at right now you
have to make sure you're careful to say
like hey are you talking about a Mexican
guy right now dude and it's like no I'm
talking about a guy who did a thing he
called yeah cops because a black guy had
a hoodie on and he thought that was
suspicious like that that also happens
but the media makes sure to focus on
when white people do it because it's
like it's all this weird [ __ ] also in
the past when this has happened
it hasn't been covered so there's a lot
of people that have past trauma that are
still alive today that are that that
basically have never seen this being
portrayed on the media as white people
being the aggressor so even though
that's been the truth for a long time so
I think it's it's an interesting time
right now we're the first
time in history citizens can talk to
each other without a filter mm-hmm so
then now you have all generations of
people that actually went through racism
people that's never been through racism
people that live in bubbles that never
heard that this stuff existed and
they're all just having this huge
argument that no one I got a ticket to
the last story now which has nothing to
do with race
but it is about anti influencing or anti
influencing so this ice cream truck in
LA went viral for this photo this owner
like he owns this ice cream truck and it
says influencers paid double that's
racist because he just got sick and
tired of influencers coming up to his
food truck and being like hey can I get
free ice cream instead of paying $4 for
this ice cream those aren't really
influences on me they're like fake few
answers yeah that's what everyone is
saying about the story it's like real
influencers when to touch it but yeah so
he just said like I'm tired of it like
they love using the word exposure and
I'm just like now you're gonna [ __ ]
pay double instead of $4 $8 so he ended
up hosting this we've decided to make
this thing official with signage we
truly don't care if you are an
influencer or how many followers you
have we will never give you a free ice
cream in exchange for a post on your
social media page it's literally four
dollars for an item or four dollars an
item well now it's eight dollars for you
hashtag influencers are gross
oh I take offense to that I'm not gross
I don't ask for free [ __ ] you can't put
me in the group like that yeah I think
he's just talking about a lot I like
that I'd be pretty sick of amphitheater
influence composers do try to save four
bucks on my jazz holy closers yeah I
mean I I do that at like parking lots
not ice cream trucks there you go you
got some standards dude yeah I'll be
like hey I'll give this parking lot some
exposure let me save the $20 on parking
yeah cuz $4 it's not much but $20 that's
an outrage dude
that's a full meal someplace [ __ ]
hashtag at for a part bite all right I
could see but I also don't know if
that's the best move for him for a
business like if cardi B shows up and
wants ice cream
and he goes oh for you $8 she might be
like [ __ ] this please so his background
is he does work in like the industry and
so he got this food truck as a side
business cuz he needed to make more
money and so he's saying like you know
he is a working actor in LA so he
understands like the importance of
marketing and promotion and stuff but
he's just saying like you know this [ __ ]
for him and he's like it's not for free
like it's only $4 it doesn't cost that
much for you to pay for my business
right yeah if you want to to post it
then that's on you I don't want to you
know miss out on my inventory yeah yeah
yeah yeah so for him that's what how he
feels about it until he also said that
there was this actress that isn't a
well-known TV show that he didn't
mentioned but her assistant came over
and tried to do the whole thing like hey
they'll take a photo in front of your
truck if you give a free ice cream oh
god [ __ ] no like I don't care how big
you are it's for [ __ ] Don I'd be
embarrassed to ask for $4 ice cream
you might dude why does Oprah get [ __ ]
gift bags when she goes to places yeah
I'm saying they I've heard that Oprah
will ask for things for free so that she
can do her favorite things things for
her magazine like she doesn't need it
she's got a billion dollars but for some
reasons and rich people love getting
[ __ ] for free like dude I got I'm
getting shaken down right now by a major
one of the [ __ ] m/m/c is they want a
[ __ ] link to my movie funny story
that just came out because they don't
want to pay $3 to watch it on YouTube
order so I got to chase down the company
and ask for a fresh link because I only
have old cuts of the movie and I'm like
waiting for the company to hit me back
because this guy is what they [ __ ] $3
to watch a [ __ ] movie I just paid $3
I don't think there's anything want
wrong with like celebrities or whatever
receiving free [ __ ] where I think is
[ __ ] up is when they're asking for it
like hey can you hook me up with that
it's like
[ __ ] you they get a tickle from it I
think that they like knowing that they
got this that they see a pleb in line
pulling out the wallet and they go I
don't have to do that I get the velvet
rope huh you know what I mean I think is
that well I'm a proud [ __ ] cuz I'm like
I got a pay
I got a pay me - yeah there was like one
point where I'm sure like me my team
were trying to figure out if we should
get this like sponsorship for free and
working deal a lot with them because
like you know I have a rate in blah blah
it's like now that I was like equating
to like okay if I get like for example
five thousand dollars worth of free [ __ ]
oh it's like not really worth it because
I would wake make way more doing other
stuff so it's like always like in the
business sense always try to like
balance out like what's more important
cuz it's like four bucks or like you
know whatever how much money it is it's
just like just pay for it yeah it's also
a warning sign I mean this guy it's not
like this guy knows who influences are
when they keys basically saying like
don't ask me about the stupid influence
or [ __ ] like here's your here's here's
what I think about that because it's not
wasting my time yeah which i think is
genius and it will save them the
embarrassment and so it's an awkward
conversation if they say no what if he
has more followers in them he's like oh
exposure [ __ ] I got more followers than
you shut up well he did say after this
going viral like his ice cream truck has
already been pretty successful because
obviously influencers want to promote it
it it looks nice yes it's called CV T it
looks like drips and swirls is it T CBT
Thank You cvts so it's a chocolate
vanilla and swirl or something like that
that's what it's a sport oh it's just
one thing chocolate or vanilla and swirl
this has been better now since this way
barrel I'd support I'm just for that
I'll be like yeah [ __ ] influencers and
then you're gonna be it can't get it for
free though yeah and he's like hey pay
double
yep
[Music]